thanks for sticking around I probably
wouldn't have but yeah it's a recently
my colleague Angus myself we've been
working on designing an implement in a
new fraud detection system at go
cordless
I found out that this chap from stripe
is doing a similar talk on a fraud
detection system so I decided to talk
more about the unbalanced data aspect
and a little bit less about the fraud
detection but that was also included as
like a secondary thing so and we start
with some of the boring stuff sorry what
is an unbalanced data sets a data set is
unbalanced when the class of interest or
the minority class is much rarer than
the other class of all classes and
they're called the majority classes and
what happens is the classification rules
that predict the small classes they tend
to be fewer they tend to be weaker than
those that predict the prevalent classes
and what you end up is with test samples
born into the small class which mr.
classified more often than those
belonging to the prevalent classes why
is this bad so often the cost of missing
a minority class is much higher than
that of missing the majority class so as
an example take cancer diagnosis if you
miss classify someone who doesn't have
cancer as having cancer then the worst
that can happen is that they'll go on to
have further tests if you might miss
classify someone that does have cancer
does not having capped cancer you know
it's pretty shitty really so the
performance of machine learning
algorithms is typically evaluated using
predictive accuracy that's the default
and a lot of the psychic learn
classifier modules but if you've got a
base rate of 99% for the majority class
and you're trying to optimize based on
accuracy really the most intelligent
thing to do there is to label everything
as the majority part when we're doing
the Ford work we were using the
cross-validation module in inside
learn and actually there's a really nice
scoring input parameter on the cross bar
score function and you can actually
alter that so that the default is
accuracy but its accuracy but you can
change that to we call precision f
measure G mean etc etcetera so that's
definitely something to to remember so
I'm going to launch right into some some
more interesting examples so exactly
this is a satellite radar image of the
sea service surface and these images are
typically used to detect oil spills
these oil spills they originate from
ships mainly and the oil slicks are
actually less reflective of radar than
the average ocean surface and so what
you end up with these black regions on
the images so the one on the right is
the or slick you also get a load of
look-alikes and these derive from
natural phenomena like Al gave rain wind
shadows and unfortunately or fortunately
however you unlike the look-alikes occur
way more frequently frequently than the
oil slicks and you end up with a hell of
a lot of false positives if you're just
when you're working or you can end up
with a hell of a lot of false positives
when you're working with these datasets
that's a really cool paper by the way
okay another example we've already
touched on this the diagnosis of cancer
I actually found it quite difficult to
find a good image for this for this
slide but an example that I did find was
using histopathological data to generate
features for machine learning and this
particular paper actually goes into it
approximates the mapping between the
data and the original feature space and
the transform data in the PCA embedding
space but they one of their big problems
is with the fact that the original
dataset is massively unbalanced
okay now my third example is fraud
detection and this is one that this kind
of most pertinent to us there are a few
papers out there on telling you know
machine learning and telecommunications
port and employee fraud and payment
fraud and this is kind of like sparked
quite a lot of interest because it makes
a lot of sense financially to kind of
pull up pull out all of these fraudulent
cases and stop them source or as soon as
possible because it costs money and boy
does it cost us money
okay
it's a go-kart this what is go cordless
we're an online direct debit provider we
serve around 800,000 people in the UK
and abroad and I'm sure everyone here
uses the rector but you probably aren't
aware of the mechanism that goes but
that's kind of behind this payment this
payment type and so what happens is a
merchant will establish a relationship
with the customer
and they want to exchange money or the
customer wants to pay the merchant
direct debit is a really cheap payment
option for the merchants offers that are
a hell of a lot lower than kind of fast
payments and so what happens is the
customer will pay go cordless or
transfer money into the go car discount
we pay out to the merchants and the
whole process from start to finish takes
between four and five days and so
actually it's a fairly short way to make
money if you're a fraud stir because
we've got a hell of a lot of time to
catch you and so we're a startup we're
fairly young with four years old and
we've up until recently we've been using
a fairly basic clunky system and the the
kind of the ratio of water to non foster
and our data in our dataset is around
two percent and so formally we used a
discrete set of rules that we chose
using Bayesian logic over time we've
added more and more rules it's kind of
created a system which was actually
really really quite messy and we've had
to employ a team of four analysts that
go through all of
data manually or and we have ford alerts
which are which I'll created
automatically
lots of which are redundant but it's
kind of we're trying to cover all bases
so this is how we're doing and actually
we're not doing too bad at detecting the
Foresters our aim is to have a recall of
one and we almost do have a recall of
one if you like the current method that
we've got in place like an ensemble
method but without but the machine
learning so there are different stages
at which we can catch a foster but we
always eventually catch them at some
point or another so yeah at the moment
we've got a recall of around 100% the
precision is 8% and we thought we could
do better so we decided to build a
classifier and we used you know the
obvious Python libraries we also use C
one and this is the first time like I do
Steve on it so it's pretty cool for data
visualization especially when we're
presenting to the rest of the company
it's a something may be worth checking
out so to start off as always a quick
and dirty model and on the left hand
side you can kind of see a basic outline
of the pipeline that we use for this
dirty model we tried a few different
classifiers we've got a framework in
place that makes it easy to test out all
these different classifiers and random
forest classifier the random forest
classifier actually perform the best we
were able to get a precision of eight
percent so that didn't change but the
recall was significantly less than one
and over here I've actually normalized
the merchant base to 1,000 to give you
get a better sense of the numbers so
where do we go from here
I mean your data I cannot stress this
enough Angus and myself we sat down for
three days going through all of the data
and what turned out was merchants that
were classified of foresters weren't
actually fraudsters they were bad news
cases a lot of the time what's a bad use
case for example chaps that sell boiler
insurance to all people they
legitimately or been granted access to
that person's account the person who set
up the direct debit it's not such a
noble way to make money because they
don't need that service so we don't want
to serve those people but really they're
not foresters so they shouldn't be
included in our model and we sat down
for three days long as myself and he
likened it to the to the job that the
YouTube reviewers have to do anything
when they looked through graphic content
because actually it was it was soldiers
to him okay so once we clean the data we
decided to resample it so this is a data
level approach to addressing the class
imbalance and that there's a few ways
that you couldn't resample the data set
under sampling is an obvious one it's
very easy you effectively remove random
instances of the majority class until
your two classes are sufficiently
balanced and the problem with under
sampling we found is that it great gave
great model statistics but we lost a
hell of a lot of information and we
ended up with a model that didn't
generalize very well and so we averted
attack went down the route but over
sampling it's kind of a bit more
difficult to show over something on a
graph so I've I've made the data points
thicker to show you that we've kind of
overlaid some on top of each other and
so obviously with over sampling you
duplicate triplicate replicate the the
minority class until you get the same
class balance that you're looking for
and then briefly I want to go through
another technique that we came across we
actually haven't gone down the street
but it's worth explaining it's fairly
new and it's called synthetic minority
over something and it effectively
involves creating synthetic examples of
the minority class so I'm going to
quickly go through the technique ok so
this is the original dataset and I'm
just going to remove the majority class
to make it easier to see so let's assume
here that the amount of over something
that we want is 200% so we choose a
sample and for each lamp or we want to
select the K nearest neighbors to it you
should decide 1k I've decided upon five
in this instance okay and we want to
over sample by 200% so we randomly
choose two neighbors from the cleanest
neighbors and then at this point we want
to generate one sample in the direction
of each of the two randomly selected
nearest odors and you want to generate
that sample along the vector joining the
original sample with with one of the
other points and what I've got here is
the over sampling graph that we actually
used that we went with and the synthetic
minority over sampling technique graph
on the right hand side and you can see
that that smoked actually forces the
decision region that there were of the
minority class to become a lot more
general and it's been shown to your
successful results in a few studies
though right so back to fraud it's all
well and good saying that we need to
over sample or resample the data set but
how do we go about doing this
scikit-learn is a babe because in
psychic learn or put 1/4 we kind of
struggled with altering the class
weights but in scikit-learn 0.16 a lot
of classifiers now have a pass weight as
an input parameter
on the classifier itself I think all
excluding Gaussian for my base to ignore
that and this saves you a hell of a lot
of hassle of having to manually up
sample in D sample and so we added a few
more steps to our pipeline obviously
this is a pipeline should be a closed
loop it's an iterative procedure but we
had a grid search and feature selection
and in the end we did we we came up with
a logistic regression model the recall
was very close to one of precision we
were able to increase to 40% that's a
five-fold increase and it's something
that our fraud team is really excited
about this is an overly simplistic
explanation of the system that we've
implemented like I said before there are
different stages at which we can capture
fraud stir prepayment prepay out blah
blah blah and there are different models
that we have to implement freeze each
stage okay so we've covered a few data
level approaches to addressing the class
imbalance and it's worth mentioning some
more of some algorithm level approaches
so cost-sensitive learning is one of
them and the goal here is actually to
minimize the cost of misclassification
and to do this implementation is
actually very similar to the reese
marketing approach and you still use the
classmate parameter but you choose the
class weights manually based on the cost
matrix which you've come up with with
the business team and I want to go
through another technique so this is I
guess it's out an algorithm level
approach it's called a de boost or
adaptive boosting it's we actually
didn't use this on the floor staff we've
been using it on some other work that
we've been doing but we've generated
some good results with it so
I thought it was worth going through it
ADA boost is short for adaptive boosting
and it's effectively a matter estimator
that you can use with a whole range of
classifiers its adaptive in the sense
that you fit a classifier once that has
been fitted you fit subsequent week week
learners and they're tweaked in favor of
those incidents which were misclassified
by the previous class why's that sounds
like a bit of a mouthful so I'm going to
quickly go through the procedure so you
begin by fitting a classifier on the
original dataset so that's the decision
boundary and you see that there were
three data points which were
misclassified and so we want to re-weigh
toes in correct misclassifications more
heavily for the next classifier that we
fit so there we fit the second pacifier
and you can actually repeat this process
any number of times depending on on yeah
how much time you have and there we have
a third class a third week classifier
and the final classifier is actually a
weighted combination of all the weak
classifiers the alphas are chosen to
minimize the overall the overall
training area era and there are lots of
variants on on adaptive boosting yeah
you should look at ensemble methods in
scikit-learn
and finally while I was doing a kind of
my research for this talk I came across
a couple of other interesting techniques
which people are using to clean their
data and so Tomic link removal the goal
here is to remove borderline examples so
Tomic links are points that are each
other's closest neighbors but which
don't share the same class label so you
can see them in circled in green on the
left hand side and what you do though is
you remove them
it kind of makes the the border between
the two different classes a lot more
distinct and then there's condensed
nearest-neighbor
the goal here is to remove instances
from the majority class that are very
distant from the digital from the
decision border and effectively what
you're doing is you're selecting the
subset of samples from the training data
such that the one nearest neighbor and
with the subset can classify the
examples almost as well as one knows
neighbor with the whole dataset okay and
so just to finish I just want to briefly
talk about what our project on fraud
detection means for the company because
that's kind of where all of this work
into addressing the problem with in
violence datasets came from so we're
introducing the norton new fraud system
at the moment is a gradual process
obviously we don't want to introduce any
breaking changes and but based on the
feature importance is that we've derived
from the work that we've done so far
we've already switched off certain chord
alerts and that's already reduced the
burden on the our team of fraud analyst
who are really happy that the the best
model was the was the logistic
regression because it's something that
is very easy to explain to the rest of
the company and what we intend to do is
to provide a fraud score to the Ford
analysts on the scale of nought to 1 so
that they can read from the dashboard
what features are contributing to such a
high flawed score when it occurs and
finally there are certainly other
considerations or other things that we
need to consider which we haven't
stationerity this is the common
assumption in many time series
techniques but we know that the mean the
variance in the autocorrelation
structure the force of failure is likely
to change over time it's something that
we're monitoring and
yeah and finally I think it was Ian that
mentioned earlier saying about keeping
your model as simple as possible lots of
people that have suggested to me using
neural networks and other nonlinear
algorithms but for us the main
challenges being you know cleaning the
data engineering more features that
takes a hell of a lot of time and
through just doing that and over
sampling we've been able to get a model
which is significantly better than the
one that we're currently using so I
finished a bit early but if you have any
questions how do you define
against a direct effort is slightly
different and more actually will sign up
to our company so it's a sign up to our
service and what they will do is they
will have acquired a load of customer
deep details stolen customer details
maliciously and what they do is they
create direct debits on behalf of those
customers and they direct Deborah is
essentially a call mechanism so they
pull the money out of those customers
accounts and then the customer will get
in touch with us because on their back
st. Lucy go cordless they've charged
back to us we're chasing money from
there from the merchants so it's a
little bit different to stripe in that
that money switches hands fire go
cordless and I don't never went to the
floor talk yesterday exactly exactly
but I mean we try to say if a Forrester
has an email address which was
previously used by afford ster we flag
that as fraud before they default the
customer obviously it's we wanted to
take them as early as possible not after
they'd afford the customer because we do
have a five day lag between the payment
being initiated and being actually
carried out so it's kind of beneficial
to all parties if we act as soon as we
come
yeah yeah I know sorry that's a good
question
we've only to be recently back we
actually have been using an ADA booster
on a different project not on the floor
project itself and we're getting good
results with that model but we actually
haven't it were kind of at the early
stage of that project so we haven't been
a lot they're looking a lot into the
future importances one thing that was
interesting actually was when that just
on the subject of feature importance
when we initially run our models without
balancing the data set random forests
came out as the best model and when we
looked at the future importances that
were generated it just didn't make sense
intuitively you know and so you know the
accuracy was obviously very high because
the base rate is so high but it was only
once we've done the resampling that you
kind of you know the results actually
match our intuition and that's like huge
because you know machine learning it is
working off the experiences of humans
right we're not and and that's something
that perhaps you had to explain to
people in the company because there'll
be a new type of fraudulent behavior and
they can't then they go test this and we
say not fraud they say oh you're wrong
we say well next time it will catch it
you know we'll just retrain the model
yeah yeah yeah that was helping yeah
yeah
okay so the question is when we
evaluated the model what level of what
false positive rate and false negative
rate would be really for the false
positive rate and the true positive rate
okay well so really I always think in
terms of recall and position but with us
that go cardless the kind of a lot of
the risk is on us if we don't catch the
foster so we you know we aim for a week
or as close to one so we want the true
positive rate to be 100% you know as far
as the false positive rate is concerned
it's very much a trade-off between the
costs of hiring you know many forth and
lists and the cost of having a huge
charge back that we have to that we have
to do is say we aim for you know our
model kind of performance we based on a
true positive rate and that yet anything
any improvement that we can get in
precision or the kind of false positive
rate is bonus to us so it's very to
detect them as forward so at the moment
we've got a precision of forty percent
if we take them detectives brought we
have the the Ford analyst actually go
through them and all of the other ones
you know not just not only the true
positives but also the what turned out
to be false positives and then yeah they
money we mark them but at the moment I
mean fraud is just so there's a lot of
clever people out there trying to do for
us and it's
taking up a lot of times that was what
spurred on this project and that's what
motivated it and yeah it's already
generating some good results so hi
oh what transformers here is a Forster
because he's interested what
transformation is on the feature space
to be honest I don't want to go into too
much detail on the features that we're
using that it's like for a fairly
sensitive topic
things like emails we used data that we
acquire from the merchants been next
line up we also looked at their payment
activity and dynamic features as well as
static features so they're they're kind
of activity using going Harless within
the previous five days day there are
some Angus can you remember any other
weird ones or not the features himself
Oh what did we do yeah we did this yeah
I mean structured not my vision but on
the features itself we didn't in terms
of engineering I can't think of a good
example of hand I think it was choosing
the features that was a bigger part of
the process as opposed to engineering
that as opposed to all between them
wants to be once we've got them
yes yes so like a one-house
classification yeah exactly that's not
the algorithm level approach to
addressing the data and balance problem
yeah we've considered it and kind of wet
down the easy route first probably and
yeah something that we might be might
consider looking at in the future but
right now we don't we don't we don't
need to we've been using anomaly
detection on something else on something
else recently it go cordless which is
looking at Ford more on a payment level
than an on an on a merchant level sorry
thank you thanks